at some point every great series must
come to an end
sometimes you get a satisfying coda to a
wonderful experience and sometimes that
eagerly anticipated series finale turns
out to be the loogie that ruins the
punchbowl as much as we all love the
walking dead it can't go on forever when
the walkers finally stop walking how do
we think it'll all go down the walkers
evolved we don't really know much about
zombie biology but we do know about
viruses viruses evolve sometimes because
of environmental factors and sometimes
against human intervention right now the
zombies are shambling hungry monsters
who hunt based on smell and sound but
what if they were capable of becoming
more zombies are strong but they're slow
and can really only use two senses the
virus in the human body seemed to have a
symbiotic relationship after death so
there's nothing really stopping the
virus from mutating these guys into a
whole new kind of zombie virus mutation
is not altogether unlikely and when that
happens
mankind is totally toast the walkers win
there are simply far more Walker's on
earth and there are living people and
even though humans possess superior
intelligence they just can't seem to
keep it together as well as the
brainless dead can humans lack unity and
zombies have an amazing persistence as
we watch the last struggling group of
survivors dwindle in a world gone wild
from neglect they'll eventually run out
of resources the food options suck
peterborough jelly diet soda and pig's
feet
I saw white trash bronzer I did and no
one seems to really pursue farming too
seriously it's a pathetic
whimpering death but it's depressingly
closer to reality than any apocalypse
we've ever seen before on TV if The
Walking Dead is one thing it's
depressing the humans win we know almost
nothing about Walker physiology other
than the fact that their guts make a
great disguise
they died when their brains are injured
and they spread a zombie making disease
but that's really about it at this point
we haven't met a single zombie that's
died of natural causes so we can only
assume that they're basically immortal
if unharmed but walkers are also easily
killed with just about anything pointy
and well aimed it's been suggested that
the walkers are Earth's answer to
environmental changes so if humans stop
acting stupid and focus on cleansing the
world of the undead the planet's ecology
will be better off than ever
zombies make amazing mulch it may not be
great for the surviving humans who have
a hankering for pizza rolls which can't
please everyone
cremation becomes mandatory and mankind
crawls back to the top of the food chain
utopia is discovered between the Walking
Dead and fear The Walking Dead we've
really only seen what's happening on the
coasts we have no idea what's happening
in the Middle States aside from some
hints of a network of park rangers we
also don't have any idea about what's
happening in the rest of the world we
see maybe 2% of what's really going on
out there which leaves a lot to the
imagination once we know that Rick's
party is truly safe we'll be able to
sleep at night and the series can end on
Marc Maron's WTF podcast producer Robert
Kirkman says he'd like to see the series
end on a positive note so real actual
measurable success isn't out of the
question a cure is found disease experts
are in pretty short supply but we've
seen labs and hospitals and sanctuaries
while it seems unlikely that someone
will whip up a zombie cure and crop-dust
the entire planet with it the discovery
of something to counteract the zombie
virus would pretty much save the world
no it won't restore grandpa to normal
but at least it'll stop him from hungry
for living flesh which is a pretty fair
compromise it ends with Rick when a show
loses its star it rarely lasts more than
a couple of seasons before totally
collapsing Rick is really the compass of
the group even when he's spinning wildly
off course while characters like Daryl
and Carol are interesting to watch
evolve The Walking Dead is Rick's story
from beginning to end and without him we
just don't have a focal point whether
Rick just can't survive the thousand
onslaught or he manages to pass from old
age or Andrew Lincoln just decides that
it's time to go Rick's story is the only
story like a canary in a coal mine once
Rick is gone start preparing for the
bitter end then again Carl storie is
also part of Rick's story we'd only like
to see Rick dying in a final episode
sort of deal where he passes the torch
of leadership to the guy who was by his
side throughout the entire zombie
apocalypse his son thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know how you think The Walking Dead will
end